[Gelächter]
ja das S
Dose ja ja zieh einfach mal dann erzähle
ich mir das nicht vor okay ich sag dir
eins die roten sind unangenehm die
Grünen sind angenehme lose es sind
Fragen ach so ist mir egal gemeine
Fragen ich ne rote und ganz harmlose
Fragen okay bittte
schön also ich lese mal vor was steht
hier steht haben sie Depressionen oder
warum ist ihre immer warum ist ihre
Musik immer so traurig ja genau ja also
Depression habe ich nicht ich muss in
die Kamera reinsprechen ne m mich jetzt
wir wieder Depression habe ich nicht und
meine Musik ist auch nicht immer nur
traurig also gar nicht ja also sie
handelt von von Erinnerung und es ist
natürlich so wenn man sich von 16
Liedern zwei aussucht für die natürlich
traurig sind dann heißt das natürlich
nicht dass meine ganze Musik traurig ist
also es gibt auch sehr se sehr viele
Lieder die nicht traurig sind die auch
einige sogar mitm Augenzwinkern zu sehen
ist zu sehen sind ja ähm gut bei geboren
um zu leben muss man natürlich ganz klar
sagen es handelt von demem verstorbenen
Freund und das ist einfach nicht witzig
aber es handelt halt vom Leben und das
gehört dazu aber ich bin nicht traurig
ich habe auch keine Depression
auch wenn es manchmal in einer Zeitung
steht dass es so wäre das ist nicht der
Fall und m ja meine Lieder sind auch
sehr lebensbejahend also g ja aber schon
schwer sie sind nicht äh
Schatz heute gehen wir shoppen oder
irgendwas nee also nee also die sind
schon die sind schon aber die haben auch
einen Hintergrund ja natürlich es ist
ein Hintergrund und der Hintergrund ist
das Leben und das Leben ist alles das
Leben ist lustig das Leben ist manchmal
hart manchmal traurig aber es die Musik
soll eine gewisse Hoffnung auch
versprühen und die Musik spricht die
Menschen an die gerade durch eine Zeit
gehen wahrscheinlich die gerade nicht so
toll ist ne aber darum
aber das meistens wird dann da drauf
reflektiert auf die äh auf geboren um zu
leben oder auf an deiner Seite das sind
natürlich Lieder die natürlich äh vom
lebenhandel in in der härtesten Form
ganz klar aber ähm wenn man zwischen den
Zeilen liest dann sieht man ganz klar
die sind sehr lebensbejahnt weil sie
handelt von Erinnerung und weiter zu
machen ja ja und das also einer der
Depressionen hat der hört ja auf klar ne
wenn einer z.B Depressionen hat der äh
der und und der denkt ja über vieles
nach und der da also diese Menschen
denken ja meistens nicht darüber nach
wie ist denn jetzt also weitergehen kann
sondern die wollen ja aufhören bist du
auch so ein Mensch
der bitte jetzt nicht missverstehen ne
kannst mich alles der auch aus dem
negativen was positives ziehen kann der
eben aus diesem total ja also ich weiß
oder ME oder die Erfahrung meines Lebens
hat mir hat es mir gezeigt bisher ich so
alt bin ich jetzt noch nicht aber es war
also ich suche regelrecht wenn was
Schlechtes ist das Positive was daraus
entstehen kann und es hilft hilft mir
auch wenn es erst Jahre später ist dann
denke ich hey wenn der das nicht
passiert gewesen wäre oder wenn jetzt
das nicht passiert wäre wäre das ja
jetzt nicht entstanden z.B kann Ken ein
kleines Beispiel
erzählen mein Freund der damals
gestorben ist das war ganz schlimm für
mich also das war für mich die
schlimmste Zeit meines Lebens mit und da
habe ich das Lied an deiner Seite
geschrieben
dieses Lied hat so viele Menschen
berührt es ich habe Briefe bekommen wo
sich Menschen wegen diesem Lied sie
sagen sie haben sich nicht umgebracht
weil sie dieses Lied gehört haben dieses
Lied hilft Ihnen dieses Lied hat
wahnsinnige
wahnsinnig viele Reaktionen
hervorgerufen und hat vielen Menschen
geholfen und ich erkläre mir das so mit
meiner
mit meiner kindlichen Erklärung sage ich
mal wenn mein Freund nicht gestorben
wäre dann hätte der vielen Menschen das
jetzt nicht gegeben oder er hätte mir
auch keine Zukunft gegeben ich habe ihm
eigentlich zu verdanken weil weil durch
an deiner Seite ja der letztendliche
Erfolg gekommen ist das ist ja das
makabere hat er mir aber im Grunde
genommen eine Zukunft geschenkt eine
musikalische und das ist das was daraus
entstanden ist also aus was schlimmem
aus was negativen kann auch immer was
positives entstehen ich will dar auch
noch mal aus persönlicher Erfahrung
direkt Nachen hast du den Eindruck dass
die Toten uns etwas hinterlassen und
zwar wirklich etwas hinterlassen also
jeder jeder jeder jeder Mensch oder
jedes Lebewesen was auf der Erde
rumwandelt und irgendwann nicht mehr da
ist das hinterlässt ein was definitiv
sei nur eine Erfahrung eine Erinnerung
oder irgendeine Kleinigkeit man ich
glaube man muss da nur offen für sein äh
das auch auch quasi so war quasi so
wahrzunehmen das klingt jetzt alles sehr
mystisch und sehr gespenstigch und äh
aber oder auch das mit meinem Freund was
er für mich quasi gemacht hat aber äh
also dass man da jetzt eine musikalische
Zukunft hat aber das sind so Dinge äh
ich glaube das ist einfachs leben also
und ich glaube alle die gehen die die
hinterlassen einfach wasm nur man äh
merkt erst viel später im ersten Moment
ist alles schlimm ist alles ganz
grässlich aber wenn man da mal so ein
bisschen wieder in ruhigere Gewässer
kommt um halt um das mal so auszudrücken
und man kann man so ein bisschen
zurückblicken und man nimmt sich echt
die Zeit und dann also denkt man darüber
nach dann wird einem vieles so bewusst
oder man kann mehr sehen bei mir ist das
so weil ich viele Interviews mache und
mir viele Fragen gestellt werden ich
muss mehr über mein Leben nachdenken als
ein anderer Mensch der keine Musik macht
und einer der viele Fragen bestellt
bekommt auch mir nachdenken und z.B äh
ich glaube ich wüsste gar nicht selber
so viel für mich selber oder hätte so
viel aus allem rausgezogen oder das Gute
in allem gefunden wenn ich nicht so
viele Fragen gestellt bekommen hätte
daher sind also Interviews für mich
immer sehr sehr dankbar weil ich immer
denke okay was wirst denn jetzt gefragt
vielleicht lernt sie ja wieder was ne
und z.B hatte mich jemand gefragt ob
denn mein Freund dafür verantwortlich
ist dass ich jetzt also Erfolg habe und
dann habe ich da lange drüber
nachgedacht letztenendes ist er großer
Teil davonm klar ist zwar makaber
irgendwo ne kann ja sagen ja jetzt hast
du deine dein Erfolg weil dein Freund
Freund gestorben ist aber
letztenendes wenn er nicht gestorben
wäre dann hätte ich das Lied nicht
geschrieben er hat es dir hinterlassen
genau das ist das hat er mir
hinterlassen und ich habe
hoffentlich also das war das beste
daraus gemacht aber ich glaube das schon
also ist das auch so ein Quell deines
Glaubens solche ja Erfahrung definitiv
und das ist für mich das eigentlich und
das zählt für mich für alles also total
also das ist so diese ich erkläre mir
meine kleine Welt so selber für mich
selber so und und es ist ein schönes
Gefühl zu zu zu wissen dass wenn jemand
geht dass man den auch irgendwann mal
wiedersieht und äh so erkläre ich mir
das wenn ich wenn ich nicht glauben
könnte dass wir uns irgendwann
wiedersehen oder h der jenige Weg wä für
immer was ist doch blöd also wobei noch
mal um dann noch mal kurz in diesen
tiefen Gewässern zu fischen der Papst
der sagt ja das ist ja das soll man
nicht man es darf nicht sich Seer seinen
Glauben selber machen aber wenn ich mir
wenn wir uns jetzt unterhalten dann
denke ich es geht doch eigentlich gar
nicht anders man kann doch nur seinen
eigenen Glauben haben ja gut ich meine
der Papst ist ja auch nch ein Mensch der
Papst hat ja auch nur eine Meinung ja
gut die behaupten schon dabei was
anderes nein aber das ist ja okay jeder
soll ja seine Meinung haben da habe ich
ja auch gar kein gar kein Problem mit ne
also das ist ja auch okay aber
ähm jeder für sich für mich ist das
anders also aber das ist ja genau dieses
Ding ich mein ich orientiere mich halt
nicht an Religion und wenn jetzt eine
Religion einen Vertreter vom lieben Gott
wählt dann ist das ja okay für die aber
das braucht ja nicht für für mich okay
zu sein und wenn er eine Meinung hat
dann akzeptiere ich das ganz klar und
finde das okay wenn er das so senkt oder
wie jeder andere wie jeder andere Mensch
auch das heißt ja nicht dass ich das
dann für mich selber dann auch so machen
muss mir tut es gut und ich tue ja
keinem anderen damit weh ganz im
Gegenteil also ich ich helfe mir ja
sogar und ist ein schönes Gefühl dann
und schönes Gefühl was keinem anderen
schadet kann nicht falsch sein denke ich
mir einfach in meiner ganz einfachen
Erklärung so gut dann gehen wir jetzt
noch
mal vielleicht zu einer grünen Frage zur
Entspannung warum ne ich find ich find
ich find ja ehrlich gesagt finde ich ja
kritische Fragen super da da hast Du
endlich mal was wo drüber reden kannst
schön den gerade gesehen haben den Müll
entsorgen hier steht was ist ihr er
volksrezept keine Ahnung also ich mache
einfach das was mir Spaß macht und das
mache ich mit Herz und versuche es halt
so zu machen dass ich mir nie die Frage
stelle
du hättest hättest doch doch was besser
schaffen können oder so oder hast du
wirklich alles gegeben und ich glaube
ich bin der festen Überzeugung wenn man
das macht was einem Spaß macht und
ähm und man ähm und man tut's mit Freude
und Hingabe dann hast du auch irgendwann
die Möglichkeit dass du Erfolg hast mm m
das ist wirklich so meine Einstellung es
gibt ja viele Leute die kümen wie man
hier in Köln sag sag warum hat mich noch
keiner entdeckt und warum habe ich
keinen Erfolg gibt es nicht etwas was
man doch haben muss um da eben einen
Schritt weiterzugehen ja du musst den
ersten Schritt machen also wenn du da
sitzt und wartest dass D ein also
entdeckt dann sitzt du da bis zum Rest
deines Lebens ich habe schon mit vielen
Künstlern gesprochen bei denen ist das
immer so gewesen die haben immer den
ersten Schritt gemacht und was ist der
erste Schritt der erste Schritt ist
einfach dich immer in der Erinnerung
rufen wenn du z.B das ist dieses Ding
wenn du Musiker bist und du schreibst
deine Lieder dann kannst du den ersten
Schritt machen indem du Lieder schreibst
wenn du aber auch davon abhängig bist
dass andere Leute deine Lieder schreiben
dann kannst du nicht den ersten Schritt
machen somit wirst du eigentlich glaube
ich du du du wirst zwar dann vielleicht
Erfolg haben aber du kannst es ja dann
nicht mehr selber steuern in dem Moment
wo ein wo dieser
Baustein Kreativität ja wegbricht das
ein anderer für D kreativ
ist glaube ich wirst du keinen Erfolg
mehr haben gut also man muss kreativ
letztlich sein man muss du musst kreativ
sein und diese Kreativität musst du auch
immer als Erster für dich selber machen
also man muss man muss einfach machen
machen machen und wenn alle Leute sagen
das ist falsch was du tust und das ist
schlecht was du tust das gefällt uns
allen nicht dann machst du trotzdem
weiter wenn du damit glücklich bist und
du gibst einfach nicht auf und auch wenn
es schwer ist du gib's einfach nicht auf
also das ist einfach dieses Rezept was
ich einfach nur jedem sagen kann lass
die anderen reden und mach das was du
gut findest mm okay du willst immer noch
willst du noch ich macht das Spaß wenn
ihr ihr müsst mir sagen das reicht jetzt
wir haben genug also wir können ger ne
also e mir macht das
Spaß finde das
wären sie gerne adelig oder warum lassen
sie sich der Graf nennen nee also ich
nenne mich der Graf weil mein
Privatleben aus der Öffentlichkeit ja
raus sein soll ich habe mir irgendwann
gesagt du brauchst ein Pseudonym weil
ich das für mich selber nicht will dass
halt irgendwann ein Kamerateam oder
irgendwie Leute zu meinen Eltern kommen
und sagen na war der der Junge schon als
Kind musikalisch oder so oder sieht der
der nächst ihnen ähnlich können es nicht
noch der Postbote sein oder so ich will
einfach nicht dass die dass meine
Familie in die Öffentlichkeit kommt und
aus dem Grunde habe ich mir Pseudonym
wählt wobei dein Name ist eigentlich
bekannt also wer recherchiert komm das
glauben die Leute ich habe das noch nie
bestätigt ich hab das noch nie bestätigt
es es gibt Kai Franz es gibt Bernt
Heinrich Graf es gibt gün
ja und Erik weiß also okay Erik weiß ist
allerdings der Fotograf irgendwann hat
mal einer von der Zeitung gesagt wie
heißt der denn ach da steht ja Name
unter dem Foto Erik weiß Erik weiß ist
der Fotograf der gute Erik super
Fotograf genau da habe ich dann gesagt
Erik ich soll so heißen wie du ne also
gut okay also ich habe den Namen noch
nie bestätigt ich werde das auch nie
letztenendlich genau wenn einer sagt
hallo Bernt oder hallo Kai dann denke
ich mir ja ist zwar schön aber bitte
respektiere das doch ich mein
Privatleben und ich habe dieses
Pseudonym weil jeder den ich gerade
treffe der neu ist oder der mich noch
nicht kennt der frag warum heißt denn du
der Graf und dann sag ich ja aberil mein
Privatleben außen vor ist und ich möchte
einfach nicht dass alle irgendwas was
was mit meinem Privatleben zu tun hat in
die Öffentlichkeit kommt ne sei es ein
Urlaubsort od sei es ein Auto oder so
das sind alles so kleine Heiligtümer
weil die die sind so eine Grenze und
daher nenne ich mich der Graf okay weil
jeder dann direkt fragt warum der Graf
bist du adlig dann sag ich nein aber
mein Privatleben ist geheim oder möchte
ich nicht dass es in die Öffentlichkeit
kommt also ist nicht geheim sondern
möchte einfach diese Grenze haben und
ähm wie machst es dann mit Freunden und
Kollegen nennen die D auch der Graf auf
der Bühne ja aber die kennen dann dann
wirklichen Namen ist das nicht ja gibt's
ja nicht irgendwann mal Übergänge wo man
es raus also da kriegt man sich einfach
leicht raus indem man beim Soundcheck
dabei ist oder nee also es ist wirklich
mittlerweile so in den letzten 10 Jahren
dass die alle Graf sagen zu mir die sind
alle Graf zu mir wie wie wie z. z.B Meer
Müller oder so auch Graf ja ja und das
hat sich so eingebürgert wir haben bei
der ersten Tour im Jahr 2000 und noch
was da habe ich nur so eine Dose mit
gehabt gesagt so jeder der mich jetzt
nicht der mich jetzt anders nennt als
Graf der der schmeißt eine Mark oder ein
Euro rein oder so und das ging dann ganz
schnell also plötzlich no Graf gesagt
ganz hypothetische Frage ich will jetzt
nicht ins Private gehen aber einfach
rein überisch du bist ja privat auch so
zu erkennen an an diesem Bart nehmen mal
an du hättest Kinder und würdest du in
Kindergarten bringen aber da gibt's doch
dann Übergang ach das ist schon wenn du
zum Zahnarzt gehst ne da z.B letztens
genau da sagen die doch ah her so und so
genau darf ich dir die Zähne polieren
genau genau also es gibt ja diese
Übergänge aber die Menschen sprech mich
drauf an sind s es oder oder bist es
bist es nicht D sag ich ja ich bin das
da brauchst du kein Wort drüber zu
verlieren die behalten das für sich weil
die wissen oder weil die das gut finden
dass ich halt keiner bin der halt der
mit der der der so mit seinem
Privatleben hausieren geht und ich finde
das B total toll und ich finde das total
klasse dass die das respektieren und
dass es auch akzeptieren finde ich
super gut dann wünsche ich
dir dass das weiterhin so klappt und
jetzt ja weilil jetzt wirst du ja
wirklich nach oben gespült jetzt kommt
vielleicht irgendwann mal die
Bildzeitung und war ja schon da ah ja
und forscht hinterher ne war ja auch
schon ja siehst du ich habe schon alles
erlebt aber es ist alles halb so wild
ich finde das nicht schlimm ja ja ich
muss ja auch dazu sagen ich muss den ich
muss ja der ob s nun der Presse ist oder
wer auch immer ich muss den Leuten die
mich nicht kennen oder die mich jetzt ja
erst kennenlernen auch erklären dass das
bei mir anders ist heutzutage ist das ja
selten heutzutage ist das ja so wie
gesagt jeder geht direkt mit seinem mit
seinem Privatleben an die Öffentlichkeit
oder da hat ein z.B ein Fußballspieler
und eine neue Freundin kriegt eine Frage
gestellt und er erzählt direkt aus
seinem Privatleben braucht einfach n
sagen e möchte gerne nicht über mein
Privatleben reden wenn er das von Anfang
an machen würde dann glaube ich dass die
Presse das auch akzeptiert aber wenn man
das einmal macht dann muss man sich
nicht wundern ja gut wobei die Frage ist
man kann es ja auch es ist ja ich ich
finde immer es eine Grenze zwischen
privat und persönlich wir haben jetzt
ein persönliches Gespräch geführt was
was sehr interessant war aber es geht
halt überhaupt nicht ins Private das ist
vollkommen in Ordnung und das finde ich
wenn man diese Grenze weiß und die ist
halt verschiebbar es ist die Frage ob
man ob schon ob ob schon dass man sagt
ich habe eine Frau und drei Kinder
Privatleben ist oder ob das noch
persönlich ist klar in dem Moment wo man
sagt ich wohne da und da und die machen
das und wen ich in dem Moment wo ich
dann sage das mit der Frau und den
Kindern dann wollen die alle wissen wie
heißen die wo woh wo gehen die hin ja
ist doch blöde und dann hat er nicht
mehr um das eigentliche zu tun was die
Musik zu tun hat ich gebe in meiner
Musik ganz viel preis ich sag z.B ich
habe ein Lied für für für meine Mutti
geschrieben oder
das ja ich habe meine Mutter oder ich
habe das Lied meiner meiner Mutter
gewidmet dann fragen die natürlich warum
dann erzähle ich das dass die immer für
mich da war mit der Musik aber immer im
Bezug zur Musik aber ich würde nie so
viel erzählen dass da irgendwelche
Informationen rauskommen die halt den
Menschen die ich liebe Schaden das ist
total wichtig für für mich ja schadet
denn Öffentlichkeit so viel bist du da
sicher oder die haben glückliches Leben
die haben sich nicht ausgesucht Musik zu
machen die haben sich nicht die haben
sich nicht ausgesucht dass ihr sohnann
plötzlich in der Öffentlichkeit steht
und für viele Leute Inter interessant
wird die konnten das selber nicht
entscheiden aus dem Grunde entscheide
ich dass sie es auch nie brauchen weil
ich es nicht mache das ist einfach
eigentlich dieses Ding wenn die zu mir
sagen würden e jetzt bist ja bekannt
jetzt will ich auch bekannt werden Daag
wenn du das gerne willst mach ne aber
letztten sind so froh eigentlich dass
sie in Ruhe ihr ganz normales Leben
führen weil ich bin Mensch ich mache das
auch gerne ich gehe gerne in die
Öffentlichkeit ich rede gerne ich
erzähle gerne aber das muss nicht jeder
gerne machen können und die haben alle
ja ihr eigenes Leben was nichts mit der
Musik zu tun hat wir haben alle ganz
normale Jobs und sowas und haben ganz
normales Leben und das sollen sie auch
weiter haben und das soll sich nicht
ändern nur weil ich jetzt äh einen
anderen Berufsweg als meem
hörgerätakustiker eingeschlagen habe gut
aber irmerin das wissen wir schon mal du
bist ist ja okay das hat ja damit zu tun
weswegen ich auch mit dem ruhigen Gefühl
halt immer was machen kann und auch den
Leuten sag sch einfach dein Hörgerät aus
und ich sag den Leuten immer wenn man
mich fragt lernt vorher was vernünftiges
bevor man mit Musik was macht oder
Kreativität Künstler ist zeichnet
Schriftsteller ist oder so all das wo
alle Leute sagen das ist doch nichts
vernünftiges ne wo alle Leute denken
Musiker sitzen am Bahnhof und spielen
Gitarre und haben Hut vor sich sitzen
lernt was vernünftiges also ich würde
wirklich sagen also echten Beruf lernen
ist wi ganz wichtig wie hast du das
geschafft das durchzuhalten also da
scheitern ja viele dran die haben eine
Leidenschaft und sag ich kann nicht
Hörgeräte Akustiker werden ich muss auf
die Bühne ja ist Blödsinn ja ja du
kannst ja auf die Bühne aber erst du
kannst ja auch während der Lehrer auf
die Bühne also ne aber da muss man schon
machen also ist wichtig also für also
für mich war es wichtig und jetzt in dem
Moment wo man halt wo so viel ist oder
so dass das so beruhigt auch ein
bisschen und es ist eine gute Erfahrung
und vor allen Dingen wenn du das dann
durchziehst und du hast die Ausbildung
dann weißt du das was dass du unbedingt
Musiker werden willst damit ne weil
irgendwann hast du da keine Lust mehr
drauf hast du genug Tinitus ja das ist
dann die Bestätigung und das macht man
dann nicht für den Beruf sondern man
macht's für die Musik den Job und dann
weiß man ob man es wirklich will gut
super Gespräch ich danke vialsön danke
auch sehr aufschlussreich einen schönen
Tag noch gleichfalls tschü
tschü